il a une vision de la france de mon
point de vue qui est fantasmé totalement
qui est une forme de vision irréel moi
je ne me retrouve pas dans ce que vous
racontez
la question n'est pas de nier qu'il ya
des problèmes dans notre pays des
problèmes profonds structurants auxquels
nous devons apporter des réponses la
question c'est de dire qu'est ce qui est
notre pays dans ce qu'il a de plus
fondamentales les valeurs républicaines
les principes de laïcité cette
communauté nationale que nous composons
qu est une communauté de citoyens qui
est une communauté de destin or j'ai
l'impression que vous passez à côté de
cet essaim celle là que vous nous
ramenez à une france étriquée rabougri
une forme de nostalgie encore une fois
indiqué qu' imaginaire la france que
vous décrivez n'existe pas mal n'a
jamais existé quand vous parlez de
l'islam
je sais pas si vous vous mettez à la
place des français de confession
musulmane qui sont autonomes à peu près
de chez millions dans notre pays 6 à 7
millions aujourd'hui
qui pour beaucoup sont des
fonctionnaires de police qui servent à
la république des enseignants qui
servent la république des médecins des
infirmières des aides soignantes qui
dans cette séquence là de que sauve des
vies plus que à l'accoutumée si je veux
dire si je puis dire avec le virus des
femmes de ménage les agents de sécurité
des commerçants des artisans et chefs
d'entreprise ces français-là de
confession musulmane vous ne les
connaissez pas vous n'en parlez pas ou
fait comme s'ils allaient cet immense
majorité de musulmans qui composent
notre pays qu'ils aiment la france qui
est attachée aux valeurs républicaines
et laïques n'existait pas ou fait si de
cette france-là de ces français-là et
vous focaliser sur des minorités que
nous devons combattre parce qu'à
l'évidence quand on aime notre pays
comme je laime on doit combattre
l'islamisme et le terrorisme ne doit pas
combattre les musulmans on doit
combattre la délinquance ond doit pas
combattre arabe les jeunes de banlieue
où les habitants de banlieue en estimant
qu'ils sont tous potentiellement des
délinquants en puissance
on doit renvoyer les immigrés en
situation irrégulière mais on doit aussi
reconnaître qu'il y à des immigrés en
situation régulière qui permettent le
développement de notre pays qui
respectent les lois de la république et
qui aiment la france autant que vous et
moi alors vallée je trouve que ce
constat que vous faites les
cataclysmique qui est potentiellement un
constat qui nous mène à une libanisation
veut beaucoup ce terme là à une forme de
dd ria si vite en fait c'est presque ce
que vous souhaiteriez j'ai l'impression
que pour servir votre campagne il
faudrait qu'ils aient des actes
terroristes ici et là et vous viendriez
vous en plaindre mais quelque part ça
servir votre logiciel monsieur zemmour
je pense que la guerre civile elle n'est
pas nos portes et quand on est candidat
à la présidentielle on a un enjeu c'est
réunir des français sur les valeurs
communes c'est faire en sorte que dans
notre pays l'unité seront créés parce
qu'effectivement il peut y avoir une
désaffection et jamais de dire une perte
de croyance aux valeurs républicaines et
laïques ce n'est pas mon cas moi je les
ai chevillée au corps moi je suis né
dans la cité des papes je suis un
provençal je suis le petit fils de
fatima hélène quand je vous entends je
suis effrayée je me dis mais de quelle
france mme par le team alors laissez lui
répond donc arriver je m'appelle karim
je n'ai pas changé de prénom parce que
là encore définir les français sous le
sceau de leur prénom si presque leur
dire si vous voulez être citoyen
français il faut gommer tout ce que vous
n'êtes qu'à preuve d'amnésie de
reniement la simulation ça veut dire
quoi pour quelqu'un qui est né dans la
cité des papes qui s'appelle qui arrive
qui aime la france et qui né entre
fatima l'aisne ça veut rien dire je ne
retrouve pas dans vos propos c'est
effrayant c'est inquiétant et moi je ne
voudrais pas eric zemmour que des
français qui aujourd'hui ne sont pas
radicaliser et l'impression que vos
discours de radicaliser est un appel
quelque part la confrontation hexagone
dont nous sommes plus que jamais d'unité
de cohésion en ne parlant pas durant
persie carême mais je termine mes
baskets occupants même pas du grand
emplacement mais plutôt en faisant appel
au grand retour des valeurs
républicaines et eric zemmour amen
mais voyez pour vous c'est une religion
la république et la laïcité or c'est le
contraire c'est très bien arriver c'est
je réponds vous prêchez la république
est bien que je reviens le croit ou vous
abonnez vous tenez un discours de
prédicateurs et vous mctu c'est à la
fois de faire fi de la réalité et de
souhaiter la guerre civile que je
redoute je le crois alors que pour moi
voyez c'est vous qui fait fi de la
réalité et c'est vous qui nous
conduisait à la guerre civile laquelle
la réalité elle est malheureusement très
simple elle est dans ses innombrables
quartier que le gouvernement lui même
appelle des quartiers de reconquête
républicaine y avait mis jamais un pied
jamais vous y arrivez je vous dirais moi
excusez moi je ne peux pas y mettre un
pied aujourd'hui oui mais j'ai grandi
vous parler de quelque chose que vous
connaissez pas bien coordonnée j ai
grandi excusez moi mais c'est donc j'ai
vu l'année dernière 60 paris oui j'ose
vous
alors justement ce que vous dites et
eric zemmour c'est un homme et un pied
vous parlez de choses que je vous dise
exactement si hop et laisser le temps
dans les quartiers excusez moi le
problème c'est que justement je ne peux
pas y mettre un pied c'est fou je me
suis retrouvé plusieurs fois dans ce
genre de quartier et je peux vous dire
que j'ai été accueilli chaleureusement
je vous raconterai un jour c'est pas
envie de raconter là je peux vous
raconter comment j'ai été accueilli à
saint-ouen par une ligne rouge à new
delhi par des jeunes qui faisaient le
guet et qui m'ont dit qu'ils n'étaient
inscrits n'étaient pas chez moi une
minorité de délinquants c'est toujours
une minorité par savez c'est toujours
menés d'entrée de dire que la majorité
des gens ne regardent et des réglages je
dis simplement je dis simplement qu'il y
a d'innombrables quartiers aujourd'hui
qui sont des enclaves étrangères tenue à
la fois par les moeurs islamique et par
les caïds de la drogue j'ai dit tenue
80% des habitants des hlm sont des
français je vous dis c'est un chiffre
que vous ne connaissez peut-être pas je
vous dis je voulais pas la nationalité
française oui même heure ce français
mais même ça vous le code tester mes
efforts isolés bien sûr que je l'aimé
bien sûr mais rien sur les murs be dans
ce que vous dites qu'elle soit la
solution existe mais la louve la
solution les solutions d'abord je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure à
monsieur caron c'est le contrôle absolu
des flux pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
nouveau parce que le problème c'est que
ces enclaves étrangères s'entretiennent
elle-même par mais moi je vous informe
incessants mais l'immigration accepte
c'était le volet l'agent g 10 jean rey
prend la connerie répond à la question
quelles séquelles et dans la deuxième
partie on va revenir dans les cartes
penser car dans ces quartiers on fait
quoi je pense d'abord ont rétabli
l'ordre par sonner la vérité on est
d'accord parce que 90% des habitants des
quartiers sont prennent alors les s'il
vous plaît super mais eric zemmour de
quelle manière parce qu'on a vu des
gouvernements successivement ils n'ont
plus de nourriture est tout simplement
mais bien sûr vous avez raison alors
donc lui même parce que mais parce que
en vérité ils ne prennent pas des
mesures efficaces savez bien vous avez
tous vu le film back nord et vous savez
bien que c'est les autorités policières
et politiques qui retiennent les
policiers ont ensuite ensuite monde à
bord ont rétabli j'ai encore fait tomber
c'est pas grave magnifique microgrammes
et celle où il tombera le son la table
sport c'est peut-être merci aux
dirigeants russes et très bien quoi
ensuite je pense qu après avoir rétabli
l'ordre nous sommes d'accord au moins
sur sa neutralité les 5% de dehlingen je
pourrais être que d'accord je vais vous
oubliez 80 on a soit les 5 toujours
votre sujet monsieur berrebi moines qui
nourrit pas cher de la pac soit les 5 et
riant avec un musée moi dire que ça que
nous avons toujours ya que ça qui nous
savons quoi je ne sais pas 5% d'abord il
faut savoir que
l'histoire est toujours faite par des
minorités se corbières le sait mieux que
quiconque deuxièmement deuxièmement
beaucoup de gens dans les quartiers
vivent de ces trafics dans les
délinquants les autres se passait
vraiment les unes ou free se lève le
matin il y en a un niveau bas y'a je ne
lis pas du tout c'est ça qui est ça je
ne renie pas du tout vous allez des
spectres qu'il y en a il y a beaucoup de
chance vous avez raison dans ces
quartiers qui vont travailler qui
travaille tous les matins qui travaille
dur je ne nie pas du qu'ils veulent
élever leurs enfants dans votre examiner
tout à fait raison je suis d'accord avec
vous parlez-en d'autant année sur la
vous en parler c'est comme les musulmans
que j'allais enfin tous les deux tout à
fait d'accord avec vous il y à aussi si
vous voulez
le problème c'est que les gens vivent
comme au pays parce que là il n'y a plus
que des musulmans et qu'est ce qu'il y a
un problème demeure ce monsieur serait
bien mais les problèmes à bélis a nommé
louis abel et musulmans pas bénésis mal
du tout avec orange humain c'est ça les
moeurs à monsieur zarabi pas durer zimri
moeurs quand on vit comme au pays on ne
peut pas vivre en france c'est une
question de mode de vie